the first of those is the development
process so how do we develop the
automated system we're going to have
therapeutic more complex systems how do
we develop them in such a way that where
we have some uniformity in that
development process and then the second
thing I want to do is I want to share
some of the data that we have in the
development that we've done with opioid
dependent patients that are already in
opioid agonist maintenance treatment so
the most effective treatment for for
opioid dependence is agonist maintenance
and that can be provided in two
different contexts can be provided in
methadone clinics traditional methadone
clinics where patients come in and
receive their medication on a daily
basis usually and they receive their
medication on daily basis and they're
provided with other services such as
individual counseling or group
counseling a more recent development is
the use of buprenorphine and
buprenorphine can be provided in a
regular primary care context it can be
provided as a prescription for patients
on a weekly two week or even a monthly
basis so patients come into the same
primary care context they receive their
other care and they can receive
treatment for their opioid dependence in
that context unfortunately we one of the
things that we do know is that we know
that adding behavioral intervention with
these two different types of treatments
ends up making the treatments better so
if you have an individual counseling or
group counseling in addition to
receiving the medication people do
better the problem is there's a lot of
limitations to those to providing those
those include costs training and
supervision of counseling if you think
of primary care context that can be very
difficult but even within traditional
methadone clinics there's often a high
turnover rate of counselors there's
constant training and supervision needs
to be done there's also staff interest
and training within that setting so if
you consider perhaps nurses being used
to provide treatment for opioid
dependence and a primary care conducts
oftentimes there may not be the same
level of interest in providing that care
because they were trained as nurses
space is always a premium and it's
becoming even a premium within
methadone clinics you have issues of
coordinating care if you provide it
off-site and you have finally patient
problems when patient comment patients
come into treatment and they initiate
treatment for this problem they want to
get their life back they want to go back
to you know having their job they want
to go back to being with their family
and doing those other real life things
that means that their time is being
taken up by those other things and so
they have less and less time that they
want to say okay yes I'll go spend two
or three hours a day receiving
behavioral interventions at us at a
separate clinic so they want to get on
with their lives as much as possible
there are number advantages that we can
provide for providing automated mobile
treatments so those are sort of
encounter to the other limitations they
provide automated treatments can provide
options for many therapeutic
interactions and I say mobile treatments
here so what I'm talking about for
mobile treatments and focusing on is
treatments that people can use anywhere
that they can take anywhere they can use
on a cell phone or a smartphone or other
device those can offer potential for
many more therapeutic interactions it
can be provided within this setting
where they're having craving where
they're having their withdraw symptoms
it provides a high degree of
confidentiality patients often don't
like talking with a therapist or a
counselor or in a group setting about
their use and they may feel that that is
not private and they'd rather have a way
that they can have interactions and work
on their behavior in a way that feels
more private to them they're obviously
low-cost and they provide consistent
presentation and they provide increased
availability and treatment for rural and
remote remote settings so want to talk
about ivr systems previous presentation
presented a straightforward IVR system
we have started to develop a more
complex set of systems that we call
therapeutic interactive voice response
they require a lot more interaction and
there's a lot more content available
than just a small number of questions
their advantages are there very low cost
their centralized they are flexible
mobile with
phone that can be used anywhere 24 hours
a day anytime they're highly accessible
from any place and there would like to
call a low high tech patients know what
these systems are there the same system
for any company you call and you receive
a phone tree that's a computer behind it
directing your call this is the same
kind of thing it's just more complex so
they're familiar with them and that
makes for a higher level of comfort even
though they can be highly complex in
addition they're easy to adapt and
change based on feedback and updates in
the science so what we've done is over
the past couple years we've developed a
system for our development an approach
for our development procedures that
involves an array of stages that are
that are iterative in that at each one
level we want to meet us a specified a
priori criteria I've listed or shown two
different levels here there's two
different one is for buprenorphine and
the others for methadone so there's two
different parallel processes it starts
by a system of generating and editing
initial modules that are based upon a
theoretical approach so based upon in
this case cognitive behavioral therapy
the second layer is then to evaluate
those modules based on counselor
acceptability and feasibility and to get
quantitative and qualitative information
back from those that is then used to
generate and improve on the system the
second level is to use that same sort of
approach but with experienced patients
patients that are within that setting
and experience with the treatment and
then to do a feasibility level of that
same thing so the key here that I want
to point out is what we call you know is
our criterion that we set it said ahead
of time and finally we have I have some
initial data to show you for initial
efficacy to
acceptability and feasibility criteria
we're trying to set these ahead of time
so that we know what we have by the time
we get out when you're a therapist the
person sitting across from you is giving
you constant feedback about what's
working for them what isn't working for
them and whether they understand words
all of those important things when you
have an automated system you don't have
any of that okay you have to have it
reach a broad group of people first and
I would like my idea of what a great
therapeutic intervention to be perfect
the first time but I know that that's
not necessarily the case so we have our
acceptability criteria and the idea is
that we want a majority of our
population to be comfortable with it we
want them to like it so we have five
point rating scale interest helpfulness
and ease of use so when the majority of
people to like that have ratings of four
or five on that scale and we want them
to use it so we want them to like it and
then to use it so with the evidence of
use we want and this is free open ended
use we want the majority of patients to
use it for more than 30 minutes that is
a arbitrary criteria at this point but
it seems comparable to what patients
often receive when the receiving
behavioral intervention next we want the
majority to use it relatively frequently
so we want them to use it more than
fifty percent of the days so this is the
initial a flowchart of the initial
system this was their first pass at this
system and what we had was we call it
the recovery line which is a comfortable
term that our patients seem to like they
have a secure login if you call this
number and you don't have a login you
don't get access they have introduction
for first-time callers and then they
have different an array of menu for
different types of options for the
modules there's help modules assessment
there's learning about which is breaking
up on the classic cbt into explaining
the concepts and then working with or
practicing the skills for us we we have
our activities being related to the
different skills and then we have what
we call an inspiration section which was
the idea of trying to have something to
get
interest in coming back ok so for
substance abuse counselors we evaluated
this for both buprenorphine and
methadone and we had them had
individuals review the system and
provide feedback regarding the
acceptability and of the system content
so six cbt therapists that were
experienced treating buprenorphine
clients provided some acceptability
criteria and the nine methadone
counselors and our acceptability
criteria was met we had greater than
fifty percent of counselors from both
groups say that they thought it was
interesting helpful and easy to use same
sort of thing we found with our patients
with our initial evaluation of patients
what we found is that of sixteen
patients that were evaluated for boop
and 12 that were evaluated for methadone
they met that level of criteria for
acceptability you can see the
buprenorphine it was sixty-nine percent
and then eighty-one percent for
helpfulness and eighty-nine percent for
ease of system use for methadone it was
sixty-seven percent interest only fifty
percent helpfulness and ninety-two
percent ease of use so we had to make
some changes we got a lot of qualitative
feedback from folks too so that meant
that we could take their feedback that
they've given us take it from the
counselors and improve on what we have
we've done that one of the first things
we got rid of any machine voice any
voice that's a machine generated
everybody hates you have to replace it
with the person that's a recorded
message we made the modules brief people
didn't want to spend a lot of time on
this they wanted to get in and get out
and get something useful out of it we
wanted it to be patient we made it
patient-driven rather than session
driven because that's what feedback was
patients wanted to be able to say I want
to use this when I want to I don't want
to have to go through a 45-minute module
in this type of context they wanted to
do activities rather than skills
practice when we had it say skills
practice they found that weird because
they were going and doing the thing they
didn't regard it as a skill they were
building and we've wanted to keep the
language simple
dumbed down so we had a review by plain
language experts we want to interactive
and engaging we did that we evaluated
the feasibility of it and we found that
we had pretty good feasibility
eighty-four percent we're using the
system for the week access that they had
grid in 30 minutes for the hbu and they
called about five times most of them
called more than fifty percent of the
days and the average call link was about
ten minutes similar types except
slightly better for the methadone side
more calls more time and slightly longer
call lengths we made some additional
changes people thought that we should
have more content we added more content
we added the capacity of the system to
have different levels so if they come if
they use the system a certain amount
they got access to more content we
included three daily questions asking
about how you're doing whether you used
in the past twenty-four since the last
call and whether you've taken your
medication and then we've added some
other type of resources and other types
of modules to the system right now we're
doing a randomized pilot I'm in the
middle of it I have a smaller sample
this is combined data I'm going to show
you it's a four-week trial it's recovery
line plus treatment as usual or
treatment as usual so it's a very
straightforward design inclusion
criteria of being on one of those two
medications using illicit drugs in the
past 30 days so we want to have
something to work on you know we don't
want to have this be for people that are
doing really well so it's for people
that are not doing so well 18 years or
older read and understand English and if
they were suicidal or homicidal or had
bipolar psychotic disorder or had a
medical condition they were not included
this is my first sort of most promising
finding which is that the self-report
seems to decrease the green bars
represent individuals that receive the
recovery line the left is prior to
treatment so the month prior to
treatment they had about 12 days of
reported use that went down to about six
days of reported use for the treatment
as usual condition
it stayed the same okay so this is
marginally significant that's it that is
correct that it's equal to point 05 a
point yes so in addition the other
outcomes are also tentative but they're
in the right direction for urine screens
there's about a twenty percent
difference if you look at the percent of
abstinent from all drugs of attested
drugs of abuse so the recovery line and
treatment is usual had about fifty
percent of abstinence from all drugs and
the treatment as usual had about twenty
eight percent so you can see this is a
pretty these are these folks are still
using a lot these are maybe in methadone
agonist or opioid agonist maintenance
but they're still using a lot of drugs
in addition if you look at the number of
drug tests there's in favor of again the
recovery line treatment as usual of 0
point eight about point eight compared
to the treatment as usual 1.2 so it's
suggesting that the poly substance use
of this group is is reduce it
potentially reducing some what we looked
at situational confidence a bit and
again there's a direction out but it's a
non-significant direction and this
finding at the bottom is probably my
thing I'm sort of most interested in we
had five people tell us that they
reported that they use the recovery line
instead of using drugs okay that they
stopped elapsed and i think that the
given how low cost many of these
treatments are that this may be where
we're getting our most benefit we may
not have to have a huge treatment effect
to have something that's useful and I
think the cost-effectiveness means that
we have to really evaluate that that
becomes more and more important all
right this is a quick idea another point
to each of the dots represents a dot of
a call of time the point I want to make
here is that the box over there
represents clinic hours and everywhere
else is non clinic hours so people are
calling when the clinic's not open
and I think that as well is really
really important point to take home is
that this is a useful add-on because
it's provided when people aren't getting
their usual treatment some additional
information about calls and a few other
things about one of the other components
on the bottom here we've had 200 people
of the tune of people that have called
and answered our question our initial
daily questions twenty-five percent or
fifty percent reported that they used
since their last call when they did that
then a giant a large majority ended up
going on to use a module that was
specifically intended to help them with
that circumstance to do urge surfing or
two to recognize and understand triggers
so they're using the system
therapeutically I believe